c'est une surprise de dernière minute
mauvaise pour besançon et la franche
comté le nouveau tribunal de commerce
spécialisé qui s'occupera des
difficultés des entreprises de plus de
250 salariés et 20 millions de chiffre
d'affaires sera donc à dijon en novembre
un projet de décret signé par la garde
des sceaux prévoyait son implantation à
besançon même ces dernières semaines
rien ne laissait prévoir un tel
revirement la commission a rendu
effectivement donc son avis le 22
février s'est récemment et dans la vie
naturellement il n'a jamais été abordé
la question de livres se dit jean plutôt
que besançon compris et maintenant notre
effarement notre surprise de voir
dimanche - totalement par hasard sans
avis en échange sans rien que le décret
effectivement venait d'être publié au
journal officiel 28 février avec tout
simplement nous en sont remplacés par
des gens dès hier dans un communiqué de
presse neuf acteurs du monde économique
franc comtois faisait part de leur
étonnement et stupéfaction en ce qui
concerne la méthode
les représentants du monde économique
considère que celle utilisée traduit de
la part de ses auteurs au mieux de la
désinvolture au pire du mépris
cette implantation à besançon devait
aussi assurer un équilibre des
territoires dans la nouvelle grande
région je crois qu'ils avaient une juste
répartition entre des grandes directions
régionales qui est entré à l'économie
qui restait à besançon d'autres qui
était à dijon et nous avons comme le
sentiment et l'impression que cette
lente hémorragie continue en direction
de dijon
clairement il y a des il y à des jeux
d'influencé appelle ça des intrigues de
palais et puis des méthodes que je ne
voudrais pas qualifié une semaine tout
juste après le décret aucune explication
officielle n'a été apportée laissant la
part belle à toutes les interprétations
sur les raisons réelles de cette
décision de dernière minute
avant